Federal prosecutors here in Germany have
arrested an employee of the country's
foreign intelligence service for
allegedly spying for Russia prosecutors
have searched the apartment and
workplace of the suspect who's been
identified only as Karsten L the head of
the agency hasn't released further
details at this time saying such
information could give Russia quote an
advantage in its intent to harm Germany
I do want to get straight across too
DW's political correspondent Simon young
for more on this story uh Simon what
more do we know
uh not much more clear than what you've
already said so just repeating this is
an employee of Germany's foreign
intelligence service the BND he's been
arrested on the orders of the federal
prosecutor accused of spying for Russia
and the allegation is that he passed
information that he obtained uh in the
line of his duties to Russian
intelligence Services during the the
course of this year
uh and there's been a search of the
suspects uh apartment and his workplace
and there is an internal investigation
uh now ongoing at the BND uh the other
thing to say is that the uh head of the
uh foreign intelligence service BND Dr
Bruno Carl has issued a rather unusual
statement in connection uh with this
arrest he has said that any detail about
this case that gets into the public
domain
um assists the enemy in its efforts to
damage uh damage Germany at the the uh
opponent rather is the word that he used
and he said went on then to say that
Russia is a particularly unscrupulous
and violent actor so clearly pointing
the finger at Moscow as being somehow
behind this story